let's talk about something about your
other favorite characters in this film
because they introduce so many new
characters there's so many yeah
I mean I feel like we're like let's look
looks but
hello hello everybody and welcome to
another episode of the after show we are
going to be deep diving today into John
Wick 4. Masterpiece is it the end for
John what's going on is there going to
be a John Wick 5 we are going to be deep
diving into all the details and the
burning questions that the film I left
behind the only way John Wick will ever
have freedom
peace
[Music]
yeah not really this is a spoiler-filled
conversation so if you have not seen
John Wick 4 and you don't want it
spoiled
stop what you're doing go spend three
hours in the movie theater and then come
right back to me and my wonderful guest
koi John Dro I am so excited when I
heard you were the guest for this
episode I was like yes I can't believe
you and I have never done this in person
I know we've talked at so many events
and so many times digitally this is the
first time we've done our jobs I know
across from each other we've been
talking about our jobs for 20 minutes
and jobs at life and how good we are at
hosts I mean obviously but I love the
existential crisis followed by
positivity we're like let's dive into
these things oh my God yeah which is
what John look felt like so yeah so
first of all before we get to our
conversation I should mention that the
Rotten Tomato scar this is a very very
fresh movie is 95 the audience score is
also 95 how often does that happen a
Critic and an audience I don't know that
I've seen that there's a couple of
instances recently I think it's been off
by a couple okay but there's also been
several instances recently like Shazam 2
where it's like the audience scores
significantly you'll almost flip the
numbers yeah and I find that it's
usually that it's usually more of a
dichotomy and I think that it's I
wouldn't say like trolling or anything
hyper negative but there is a a zealousy
to the audience that sometimes they get
defensive when they see the score is bad
by the way they attack they want it in a
very strong way positive positive yeah
sometimes people are like we don't like
this thing that you did but it's
interesting to see the exact same
perspective from the audience and the
critics and I would love this to be an
opportunity for people to go like oh
Rotten Tomatoes does have a perspective
that I share because more often than not
it's about people going like why is
Rotten Tomatoes different than me or
like critics aren't real people which is
a weird even concept that's a whole
conversation yeah yeah but I think that
the the sharing of it that's another
highlight of this film is that critics
feel the same fondness that the audience
does and critics have a certain language
critics have a certain uh familiarity
and skill set that the day-to-day
audience doesn't have but they both see
it the same that's the strength of this
franchise well let's talk about the
strength of this film and and people do
consider this to be the best John Wick
movie one of the best action movies of
all time do you concur I I put one uh
just a smidge ahead of it really just
tiny amount can I guess uh please I'd
love to hear one one yeah yeah correct
um okay well I could I I think from
story perspective yeah one is better yep
I don't think anything could top one
origin stories are always hard to top
and they're hard to you need a
foundation that's so strong yeah to get
to a four yeah it's really rare that a
sequel can live up to the first one and
I'm not saying the action does I'm not
saying moments don't but there's
something so eloquent and linear about
the balletic movement and the style and
the the the Precision in the first one
is so specific to me I love the fact
that there's bullets being counted and
the gunfu kind of has this really it's
not grounded in reality but it's
grounded in something and I I feel like
as you escalate into sequels you have to
change that and I think that four does
it better than the other sequels but it
still wasn't able to have the number of
bullets be counted have some of those
elements like tie in so for me the first
one is just just a smidge but I think
that this is one of the best sequels of
all time and I would argue that though
the first movie is a better movie I
would put this up against like your Fury
roads your t2s like this isn't the best
action of all time conversation it's
just tricky because I put John Wick
slightly above it as its own thing I
actually this is my favorite John Wick
movie overall yeah the first one
award like I said in terms of emotion
and story I think that's a better film
story wise there's all kinds of stuff in
here there's so much more action it's
action driven and it's these huge it's
you know story in between these huge set
pieces right rather than the other way
around aliens like it's a different type
of film yeah so this actually I thought
was the best and and in terms of
how I felt watching the movie there was
two moments where my heart was
absolutely coming through my chest the
card scene the card oh yeah scene there
was so much suspense and look I knew it
was only an hour in an hour and change
it I knew he was gonna be okay but it's
still like how's he gonna get out of
this and then of course the Duel at the
end but I don't remember I think the
last time I felt this way and this
engrossed in this you know involved in a
film where it just took my breath away
and made me forget about everything in
my life was top gun Maverick last year I
think that was the only other time I
felt that way recently yeah we need to
look at this as a very unique age of
film like people aren't realizing we're
always complaining about bygone eras
because that's how we map our brains but
I think we're living in Creed 3 John
Wick 4 Top Gun 2. sequels are really
good yeah right now and we're letting
these films have a legacy that is in and
out of universe relevant yeah John Wick
is a great example of trusting the
audience and believing in your product
and making it the movie it has to be to
fulfill the destiny of being a fourth
and there's a reason it keeps going up
like there's a reason every one of them
opens bigger than the last like the
audience grows it Finds Its its own tone
but it trusts the audience to be absurd
like there's so many moments that would
literally kill everyone on screen that
we go no it says John Wick we've earned
this suspension of disbelief yeah and I
honestly think that there's also some
fun tie-ins like uh his bounty in this
film is 14 million which is how much uh
the first one's budget was you know so
what's John Wick worth 14 million that's
what it costs I love that what I think
is so funny is when they were discussing
with uh nobody when he was discussing
the price at the end and the Marquee was
like I don't know if I want to go to you
know 30 or 33 and I'm like it's your
life yeah do you remember in Jurassic in
the third Jurassic movie when they were
auctioning off the dinosaurs it was like
you're starting at 20 million those are
dinosaurs I think the bounty on John's
head should have started at a hundred
I'm so sorry it was absurd because my
brain and I get I like that sorry I said
I said budget I'm in box office uh I
mean the other way around yeah but I I
really like that they they gave us a
cheeky tie in but also the whole time I
was like those people have done way
worse for way less like what do you mean
that many dollars the same as the
dinosaur thing the numbers felt like a
little bit of uh not in Universe
realistic yeah so let's start let's dive
into the characters a little bit at some
of our favorite moments first let's
start with Keanu there was something
when I was watching it that I was
thinking there's very few actors and I'm
gonna go back to Top Gun Tom uh Tom
Cruise I almost said Tom Hanks but he's
one of them too Tom Cruise is one of
them where I can't like there's almost
you know there's been studies in in
Japan I think about how Tom Cruise
actually can there's something about his
personality that's very hypnotizing and
they've actually done studies into
people's brains and Tom Cruise is
affected on people's brains when they
watch them in film I feel like Keanu
Reeves as John Wick or maybe in every
film is has the same thing he's mesmeric
there's something to him he is so
mesmeric and hid the Cadence people are
sort of talking about the Cadence and
how is he how he's really like as the as
every film has evolved the way he talks
and the way he Paces out the dialogue
that he is he's sort of really amped it
up do you feel that well I find so I I
think of the John Wick movies as being a
meditation on peace through violence and
I find that each one of his movies
always there's like a dichotomy to it
and I think that's what I'm mesmerized
by and then his his delivery is what
makes it feel tangible so like uh the
Berserker comic that I'm obsessed with
that feels like it's it's a book about
immortality that he writes that feels
like a meditation on mortality so like
he and Matt Kent this great comic writer
write this story that feels like it's
it's human beings struggling to cope
with their mortality by writing
immortality so for me Keanu Reeves
playing John Wick feels like a man who's
so peaceful that he plays a man that is
so violent as a way to release and be
peaceful so his his pacing is Cadence is
pentameter his Vibe his energy all of
that feels so at peace because of the
violence and I think that's very intense
and very intentional and I think Keanu
Reeves wants roles like that where he
can like wield his very specific tool to
be the man that can land that no one
else could no one else can hi John Wick
yeah and and I love that for him because
like how many times has he had a
franchise like I I don't know if there's
another more bankable franchise star
because Tom Cruise is like you know
maybe the longest running movie star
yeah but you speed change Cinema Bill
and Ted changed comedy in cinema uh you
know the Matrix is as close to religion
as I understand to have and then this is
like this happened in his like 40s 50s
and they couldn't sell the movie it was
gonna be like a Walmart five dollar bill
like that's insane I know I know thank
you and then that reminds me too of like
the last the line about the life and the
death about some people live with death
and what do you remember what the line
was such a good line but it was
something about that really reflected
John Wick as a character yeah the thesis
statement in the whole thing
um all right so let's let's talk about
something about your other favorite
characters in this film because they
introduced so many new characters
there's so many yeah
I mean I feel like we're like let's
we'll get to others because there's a
few other really yeah but Donnie Yen as
Kane I mean this is the thing like
Donnie and I guess you know he does he's
had a few things in Hollywood that
haven't really you know he was a little
bit reluctant to sign on he really
crafted that care he really you know
they he and Chad sat down and really
fleshed out that character uh but yeah
go tell me what you're tell me what your
thoughts are the duality of man is is
these two characters it's it's it's
isolation and wanting and yearning
versus having and not being able to have
it it's it's a man who has everything
that can't actually have everything
because the deal with the devily made
versus a man who lost everything that
doesn't know what he's fighting for like
if you look at you know the psychology
it's really fascinating because I feel
like those are two hardcore archetypal
figures that aren't usually shown this
way neither is seen as really good or
bad Donnie n is so Charming he doesn't
become an antagonist at no point you
really feel like he's the bad guy but
you want to because you love Keanu
Reeves and and there are moments when
you identify with both of them needing
to kill the other and you're you're as
an audience member going like if he has
a daughter what's Keanu living for which
is why I think that wasn't a flaw I
think the moment we both had was the
strength of the film going like you
should be thinking this until the end
yeah but I think jumping to the end I
mean this is a spoiler-filled discussion
but jumping to the end I feel like John
knew what he was doing he knew what he
was doing and he I don't know if he
missed the two shots on purpose oh I
think he did I think from the beginning
his plan was to take out someone big
enough to cause an impact but know that
the power vacuum is going to fill it in
but have peace knowing that he's done
something that he's sought to do I think
all the films like the first one he's
back and the second one he's got to do
this Mission and the third one he's
taking out the higher chairs and the
fourth one he knows he can't solve the
problem but he wants to take out someone
big enough to feel like he did something
and go go at peace and and he I feel
like he wanted to just be free and clear
to the high table and once that moment
happened
he dies yeah we'll get you but uh yeah
that that was maybe his purpose his
purpose was just to set his soul free in
a sense and his purpose up until this
movie I felt was to he wanted to stay
alive to keep his wife's memory alive
because he had said if I'm alive I can
think about her and that keeps her alive
in a sense which is his last moment if
it was these last moments he was and
here's the thing like I usually have a
hard time I sometimes think death is a
scapegoat for for writers that can't
finish a story I I have felt like that I
didn't feel like that this time and I
didn't feel like this time around I feel
like sometimes it's too easy and when
people say no but he had to die even end
game I mean I didn't like that I did not
like the iron I literally thought in
that in the moment you said it was like
that's an example of another time that
worked for me what I loved about this
one and maybe it's also because there
potentially could be a John Wick 5 we
don't know they didn't show a close-up
of him dying and I did appreciate that
because I don't like the oh my God it's
just not whether he died or not that's
not the movie I think sometimes it's the
execution yeah okay so let's let's go
back a little bit then we'll dive
forward into the end and whether or not
he's actually he's actually any other
standouts for you I mean Scott Adkins as
Kayla was so much fun uh I did not
recognize him on the phone at one point
I I went to the premiere and he was
standing like adjacent his poster and I
went and that's when I realized I I was
about to see the movie and I'm a huge
Scott Atkins fan it took until
physically going oh and then it was such
a great experience watching the movie
being a fan of Scott Atkins going like
this is incredible because the way he
was able to move in that suit and the
way he was able to be like a
kingpin-esque force like the way he
fought was so unique because Scott
Atkins can do anything so it was cool to
see him like lean more kicks because the
way his physicality would be is his legs
would be stronger and his Center would
be different and I love that they played
with the physicality of the stunts to
his body type and they did that really
well with Donnie Yen as well the way
they played with
um the the blindness with the the
doorbell moments like there are certain
elements that really allowed him to see
or hear in a strong way and I really
think that everyone that's a boss fight
in this felt like a video game where
you're like this boss fight would be
this unique skill this would be this
unique skill and then the running thread
of like the guy with the dog is such an
uh a great like sidekick antagonist
where you're not sure where he's gonna
land yeah I love that element okay
Shamir Anderson genius I've never seen
it before I had never seen him before
either and I guess he did a movie with
Halle Berry and Chad was a producer on
it and so he just offered him the real
flat out he didn't even read for it wow
he is a star 100 every time he was on
screen I was fascinated by him I didn't
love the choice I'll tell you this I
didn't love the choice again goes back
to close-ups at the end when they had
the duel and they kept going back to his
close-ups I felt like
they just kept going to a close-up and
you could I in my brain because we used
to be actors I was like I could see them
on set he shot it by himself close up on
his face and said okay now John's dying
okay now John took the shot okay and he
had to react right and his acting was
brilliant I just felt like it took like
it didn't feel like it pieced together
with the rest of the story my issue was
it kept being like this guy's important
it it kept it kept telegraphed indicated
at no point was he not important I don't
need to be told at the end of the movie
he's important yes he's been important
yeah like I was gonna kill him and now I
kind of see yeah that kid's got
something that's the trust in the
audience thing yeah that was the one
time I felt like they didn't trust the
audience because I hate movies when
there's like a flashback to 20 minutes
ago it's like we were there and like
this felt like that it's like it's like
oh yeah no I got it and this felt like
that but like the Montage at the end of
the movie when they go back and they
show you the whole movie again minutes
we were here with you the whole time I
didn't leave if I peed it wasn't that
long and like so when when it happened I
was like we've been we've been with him
we like him we we I got you and so that
was the only time the movie felt like
telegraphing but it wasn't enough to
make me dislike any of it to an uh a
problem but he definitely felt strong
enough to carry his own movie throughout
well I think he should have do you agree
that he should have a spin-off his story
would be so fascinating yeah I Am Legend
without the bad writing I want that
don't badly adapt one of the best novels
of all time come on and it's interesting
because Chad said I guess his original
cut was three hours and 45 minutes and
somebody asked him recently what did you
cut out and they said a lot some of his
scenes
um in Berlin that there was more
interaction between him and John and I
wish we had one more scene between the
two of them that fleshed out the
relationship or where he was coming from
I feel like I just had I I just wanted
one more one more Nuance of their
relationship would have been nice with a
little bit more of like why are you
doing this what is this how are you
related yeah I agree yeah and then when
he spares the dog when piano spares the
dog as soon as that happened John I'm
like John's dying right that was his
full circle moment closure but did he
have to say the dog's kind of evil I
would have been funny
I love that dog that dog did the work if
there's a dog that you can take out you
could take out that dog who's just
listening to his owner you'll like the
owner but not the dog no I love the dog
but I feel like there was too many in
the movie there was too many like kill
in the movie like I think there was four
or five times you became like he became
like a character Resident Evil like
launched it it felt like a video game
where you're like dog have a spin-off
I'm all in I would watch Air Bud John
Wick Edition all day I'm ready yes no
but I think I honestly think that that
that and actually I think as a as we are
I don't know when this will air but as
we're recording today one of The
Producers has just set announced there's
going to be a new John Wick spin-off
that they haven't previously announced
almost guarantee it's him if it's not
him I think it's the uh daughter of the
Akira yes
who's a pop star apparently and he just
like straight up offered the role
apparently like yeah like faster on
social media yeah and was like oh she's
got the look or she's got the energy or
something and she had great presents I
think she has a little work to do as an
actress personally but she did gravitas
for days yeah and I think she was up
against like and they've already lived
in these roles I can't imagine joining a
franchise on the fourth one like not
only are these Keanu Reeves and Lawrence
Fishburne but like they're living in and
roles they've played right that's so
much harder so do you think that's the
spin-off because I I don't know about if
Donnie Yen I mean I feel like at the end
it's so ambiguous whether or not because
does he look at her does he see her
coming or I think his expression changes
when they cut to black but I want that I
like the ambiguity there
it's the character way more excited I
think Sopranos was the greatest ending
of all time I love ambiguity and people
arguing about what it meant I love how
the thing ends and you're like what I
love that I I would prefer it not be
that story it just felt like that's why
they were setting it up but I I would
rather same him and the dog I'd rather
go that way I mean a continental show is
going to be exciting because I think
that's really like well versed in
setting up a lot of things you gotta
like guest stars you have people yeah in
and out like yeah the cast works and
then ballerina I think is genius because
andarmus should be a bond
bonds like anatomas is like a spy like
just ready to make it yeah so like her
in this world genius how do you feel
about that I know I'm jumping Way
Forward in our conversation but this is
where it's going how do you feel about
who's directing it is
how do you feel about him as a director
because like some people are like oh my
gosh only Chad should be doing these
like it's it's you know part of what
makes these work is Chad is just he
lives and breathes and embodies this
material yeah and such a brilliant how
do you feel about Len as a choice I
would prefer that
how do I phrase this I would prefer the
spin-offs be directed by other people to
keep the strength of the John Wick line
clean and let the other films have
slightly different tones because I think
that's the only way a shared universes
work I think that if you let a shared
Universe if you trust your audience to
have the slight differences you got you
know references you've got Styles you've
got stunt things that tie in but you let
different directors have their their
piece it's like comic books having a
writer and an artist do this and then
this and then the team up works but I I
don't want everything to stay with one
director if it's spin-offs because I
think then it becomes like why don't you
just call it John Wick 5. so I I
personally think it's going to be a
string I like Lynn Wiseman though so
maybe I'm biased like I think the
underworld movies are really slept on I
think that like he's such a a passionate
director
um I I didn't love Total Recall but I
loved what he wanted to make every time
he talked about it I was like that's so
passionate and that felt like a studio
versus director issue but overall like
you know he's such a vision oriented
director and he's got such a precise
thing he wants I think as long as he has
the right stunt team it's going to be
the right movie but I I do think it
should feel a little different I do too
I mean look this is Lionsgate big baby
this is their this is their franchise
baby they're not going to put it in the
wrong hands they had a choice of they
had to pick one person and that's who
they chose and Chad you know and he are
friends and he gave his Blessing and all
that so and like David Leach look at
like the relationship between Chad and
David Beach and like he's still around
he's still supporting like that's still
a family that's still a team you know he
was around for the first John Wick and
then he went off and made you know
Deadpool and bullet train and these
other things that are they feel very
John Wick but they're his tone whereas I
feel like Chad has had the time to like
marinate and only Wick and like just
perfect it like make the sauce and it's
been cooking for four movies and like I
want the wick world to stay and if I
want to just watch John Wick I've got
that option but then I've got all these
little fun side missions that should
feel a little different so let's talk
about the sauce of this movie Yes
favorite let's talk let's go through
this episode let's start with Osaka okay
and and that whole action sequence so
unfortunately when I saw this movie I
kind of had already had the movie
spoiled I kind of already knew what was
going to happen I knew the last hour was
Paris I knew a lot of it
um that said when I saw the Osaka set
pieces and I think a lot of it was
because the that was the real
introduction to Donnie Yen and and Kane
and those cool you know that cool room
and I just felt like maybe a tad too
long but other than that I thought how
are they gonna top this like I I knew
they were going I knew everybody said
like the last hour in Paris is the best
hour I was like how are they pretty it
felt like a third act you're right it
did it immediately it was like any other
movie this would have been a third act
and that's what a four can do again it's
trusting your audience yeah I I love the
opening I really think that this movie
could have even been longer uh I'd love
to see that three hour 45 minutes oh
people are going to want to see it oh
yeah and the opening opening the
Lawrence of Arabia yes what brilliant
beautiful like brilliant it's just the
scope you open with the scope like that
he's like welcome to John Wick like so
incredible yeah and just the black suit
and it's Keanu Reeves and he's like the
man walks so specifically he's got this
people talk about his Cadence verbally
his Cadence physically is what I'm
fascinated by he's got certain like hand
gestures and certain ways he throws his
shoulders in the same way a lot of
people throw their hips and the way he
moves his legs is unique to him I you
can tell when it's another stunt guy
because Keanu moves so specific so Keanu
does his own stunts oh you can tell oh I
can tell yeah because Keanu moves like
it's like a fingerprint like Keanu moves
so uniquely and he did 80 of his own
stunts and I only I I can only tell two
stunt moments weren't him because of the
specificity of how he gets up there's a
moment in the stairs
um that it literally was just the way he
put his arm down and lifted himself up
wasn't Keanu which is creepy to say on
Rotten Tomatoes but like you can tell
like physicality is so important for
we're gonna talk about later but uh
stunt performance are the visual version
of dialogue what stunt people do with
their bodies is what Shakespeare does
with words when you look at a frame when
you experience a movie what's happening
in that frame is Visual and auditory but
the visual of so many of our favorite
movies is stunt people telling you a
story with their bodies and there's no
reason there should be an Oscar and this
movie is a great example of what you can
do when you have a stunt team that knows
not only martial arts but but film arts
and and Keanu Reeves knows both more
than maybe anybody like I get Tom Cruise
as the ultimate stunt performer but his
stunts are it's a different type of stun
it's not hand-to-hand combat this is to
me Fury Road for hand-to-hand weaponized
combat like what they did for car chase
is this is the bar now for weaponized
hand-to-hand combat yeah and I think
Keanu Reeves being who who he is and his
physicality is is the reason for that so
uh that opening sequence in Arabia no
one else could even walk like Keanu
Reeves like if you if you have a wide
and it's a guy like way off you know
it's not him but I love how many shots
Chad actually does of Chan who's walking
and feet yeah throughout the movie there
are so many because he's so fascinated
so fascinating agree so yeah so so Osaka
um anything else you wanna uh I mean
favorites uh highlights where I briefly
said at the top um dollhouse uh Frogger
and um the rocky stairs are how I've
determined my three favorite set pieces
the dollhouse sequence is maybe my top
five action scenes of all time uh it's
up there with the blade Blood Rave it's
up there with um you know Fury roads
tent pole uh on fire moment like there
are certain set pieces that you are
watching it in the theater and you're
like this has changed me like I when
you're in it and you're like I know I'm
gonna think about this the rest of my
life that dollhouse scene is that for me
I have never felt quite the same level
of like oh over there like in a movie
when you watch people watch movies like
scream or whatever when they're yelling
at the screen I felt like that but I was
at the premiere so I'm like keep it
together man like don't you yell at this
giant screen there's the cast oh I was
yelling at the giant screen I wanted to
so bad because it was just so much
action it was so intense and it was so
original it was so inventive when you
look at choreography he had to re-write
choreography effectively because you
don't choreograph aerially for that long
if you if you think about the language
of film you're so aware of the z-axis
which is you know you're you're to and
fro that you're choreographing you're
like a side scroller and you're you're
dealing with things coming into your
z-axis and that's what makes it so
exciting and why you can have certain
stun performers be like oh shaking it
off and get back up and you can kind of
play with the z-axis so your your brain
can't handle that much stimuli so you
can allow for certain things but if you
go over the top now your z-axis is
literally up and down so you just got
like this this dot of a man and your
brain rain doesn't go okay it's a video
game now but it goes I've never seen
anything like this before and how do you
make little moments this way exciting
because it's it's a different format
like it's it's a new way to film
anything and so that set piece is not
only rewriting choreography rewriting
stunts rewriting how you film an action
scene but it does it with a flamethrower
it does it with this dragon's breath so
it's it's what 50 stunt performers all
coming at them you've got actual fire
choreography on top of it and the timing
I mean
like a lot of that is is I mean there's
obviously there has to be some Cuts but
like it is though it is a Wonder for
days like that scene is I think the best
action scene of the year a hundred
percent I agree with you nothing tops
that one that one in the Frogger scene
to me because that one as brilliant as
it is you see it from the you know when
you're seeing it for the bird's eye view
I can understand my brain can process
how they did it sure my brain can't
process how they did the Frogger scene
yeah
and and and Chad talked about how they
did it and he said because I guess you
can only shoot there and they shot
during the pandemic so there was so they
had a little bit more time around the
Arctic Triumph but he said they
basically took images of it and then
they rebuilt that set and then they
stitched it together and that was the
only way because they would never have
had enough time to fill that film that
sequence at the actual Arc of Triumph
and I think it's just like
the speed at which the cars were coming
the number I I don't know how as
brilliant as you know stunt performers
are as brilliant as choreographers are
my brain is going to need to see that
scene I've only seen the movie Once
several more times before I can even
start to like it's moving faster than my
eye can and the stitching is so good you
can't tell in the CGI like I love the
fact that we're at the point of CGI
where those visual effects artists were
so good you don't know when it becomes
like not a physical body yeah yeah like
a lot of people have died if they
weren't stitching but they clearly did
but I only know that because of like no
one died like I I only know that it
wasn't a a stunt performer in certain
moments because there was no fatality on
set otherwise my brain can't comprehend
that is such an impressive feat does
your brain have a problem at all with
the fact that Keanu should have died
falling down the stairs
um with many cars with what I'm calling
him
um I'm calling him Brendan Frazier from
the whale but it's actually Scott Atkins
I was
you should get an Oscar nomination for
being the Brendan Fraser of the whale of
the actions of the action World um Killa
like in that scene when he throws him
off the thing and then for me the
dollhouse scene when he falls out of the
window and he lands on the car like that
was the moment where I was the loudest
in the theater when he hit the car and
his body snaps in half basically yeah
and you know then he falls down the
stairs and then he gets back up does any
of that bother you that's the only
critique that people are sort of having
about the film is that like at some
point it gets ridiculous and some people
are saying in their test screenings
people were laughing or you know in some
audience screenings but I don't it
doesn't bother me I guess this is the
second movie it would bother me you know
what I mean like I think that we want
more and more more and they have to so I
remember thinking consciously like hmm
he'd be dead and like then as soon as I
had said that aloud in my head I got
over it so I remember consciously having
to go like I accept this reality Looney
Tunes physics are here yes and there are
moments that like there's a relief in
that there's a there's a comedy in it
kind of like jackass I think the reason
jackass is so entertaining is
we as humans are afraid of pain so we
get a rush of adrenaline and and your
diaphragm like the reason laughing and
crying are so similar is it's a very
similar physical experience your
diaphragm is seizing and you're having
an emotional reaction your brain doesn't
always know which one's which and I
think sometimes when you're tense like
we've been talking about and you like
can't you need that diaphragm spasm
that's why uh some writers throw in a
line of comedy in action movies some
throw in uh you know horrific Gore I
think this is
is the pain and but they don't even give
you that moment because when he does get
up typically they would give in maybe
another movie they might give an actor
some time or recovery right and they
don't do that all you do is that gasp
you get that like one exhale and then
it's right back to it but I think
without those moments then it would have
just stayed tense like you need to play
The Equalizer of the The Human
Experience like you need to be the
orchestra going like breathe and we're
back so I think he needed to almost die
or you would have died a lot for us to
be like okay this is insane still why
did Kane help him up the stairs why do
you think he helped him really
friendship and honor he like I at first
knowing that he could potentially die
him he's going up against John Wick he's
blind I think he knew really I think he
knew his friend
would protect his daughter I think from
I think from the moment he was assigned
that he knew the problem was going to be
him making the decision I think he
trusted John so much that he had to kill
John or John was going to do what he did
at the end I I don't think there was not
a moment hesitation uh I think my first
thought was the honor of fighting a
worthy opponent but then like little
moments like him slicing his hand and
stuff was like just like yeah what was
that that was balanced like I just I did
you uh I prevented you a handicap
there's a little handicap for me like
you you know you you got to take you
down a peck like I just saved you a lot
of stuff here's a little bit like you're
gonna pay it back like it's uh was it it
was just shooting hand too wasn't it
yeah so like a a blood uh trade like you
know a moment of of balance so to me it
was I you know a worthy opponent Legacy
friendship all that but mainly trust
like he he trusted that character to do
what was right there's a real hand theme
in this franchise because it is with
like nobody's hands oh
that would be like
I don't watch medical shows
why I can't even watch if I can't can I
don't watch horror movies like I I uh I
like scream I like the black phone I
like I ended up learning this right in
this real time uh but yeah I can't watch
horror and Gore I can't like because I
think I connect too much I'm too in like
we both talked about getting physically
anxious in action yeah when I watch Gore
I'm like why would I put my brain in a
position to think this is real like why
would I do this to me and like I the
world's dark I don't need to put it in
my brain so like when there's Gore and
stuff I'm just like not for me and I
that moment I fully turn hey did you
watch did you watch when
um it's a character's name Chidi dies on
the stairs did you watch what the dog
did after he killed him I didn't watch
that part I I definitely watched that
part for that I think it's also like a
uh revenge is interesting like there's a
Vengeance to violence that sometimes
feels Justified versus 100 that didn't
feel I mean I get the story purpose but
I didn't want to see it whereas
someone's suffering that feels like
they've earned it that that feels
different yeah like seeing bad people
get hurt feels different than seeing
good people get hurt and we like that
guy so like I didn't want to watch him
get hurt so what do we think of Bill
Skarsgard as the main villain what did
you think is I had an interesting take
and then it changed what did you think
of him initially
um even though
um rest in peace Lance Reddick even
though he killed the concierge that was
sort of your way into hating him right
like he's so evil and then he did it in
front of Winston and like it was like
you know that was kind of like watch
your you know your your partner die in
front of you and I'm gonna spare you the
thing the thing that didn't work for me
story wise was when
um when Winston's character came to him
to tell him about the duel yeah he just
accepted it why didn't he just pop him
so that was my issue I was wondering if
you were going to bring it up because I
I was trying to think of a way to tie in
his petulance with the movies overall
like everyone's an 11 and I feel like it
was almost there I feel like Skarsgard
always plays in 11 so maybe I'm just as
a fan watching this going like that's
the man what's what that's what he does
that's his work and um I think that was
my only issue with him was that everyone
else felt like they were very in-world
whereas he felt slightly out of the the
tone but I still enjoyed him enough it
didn't but it never took me out but
there were moments where I was like that
feels odd it just feels a little see
that in a sense and it worked for me as
I thought about it afterwards because he
did feel removed from sort of like the
villainry like the typical villainry
um but sometimes leaders are like that
in a sense sure you kind of wonder how
they got to where they did right right
and that was fun like I liked seeing him
play because he didn't really show you
like he never got in on the action he
was kind of late and it was like
everybody would follow and it was like
why why is he the Marquis how did he
become the Marquee I would be interested
in seeing his story and how he became
the Marquee because it almost didn't he
seemed like such a coward yeah that it
was just like how did he become the guy
but then just you know in in early he
sort of said earlier on like he doesn't
play by the rules so why was he playing
by the rules in that moment like why
didn't he just pop Winston and be like
I'm not doing any duels this is done and
when they sat down in front of the
Eiffel Tower to decide when and they
were turning over the things why did he
say because his vote was not in the
sunrise the next day and John Wick was
like right now why didn't he say a week
from Thursday and just have the chance
to just have like a week and a half to
have his other guys that was also a
great sequence though the the I mean
that led to ultratron but that entire
chase that went on like yeah that was
like a 40 minute movie of just like them
pursuing John Wick because of this guy's
order that was that wasn't yeah and if
you've ever been to Paris none of it
makes sense because why would the boat
drop him off where they did to go
through the Arc de Triomphe to get to
the sacracore and by the way you don't
need to go up to the steps of sacracore
you can get dropped off around the back
this has been every Boston movie every
time Boston's a movie I'm like that's
not where the Mystic is what are you
doing or like in in um uh ambulance
where they like they leave the
convention center and then like 20
minutes back at the convention center
I'm like where did they go they just
take a left like what is this just I
mean this is totally random but in the
holiday when Kate Winslet arrives in the
U.S and she goes along the PCH to get to
Beverly Hills I'm like that doesn't
happen you take the 40 freaking five to
get to Beverly Hills this is why The
Californians get exists is because we're
so proud of knowing the roads like we're
just like that's not how that works at
all in the in the fighter uh Christian
Bale runs across a bridge and he runs by
my house on the other side but in the
shot of him running he's running the
wrong way and so the only time like so
when I watch it I'm like that's my house
that's how my house is and it's so funny
because whenever I watch that movie I
love that movie so much yeah my
hometown's lull so it's funny to see
those moments and tie yourself to them
emotionally but this one did a great
service to Paris and where it traveled
because it felt like you were living in
that world
you 100 did and you that was like the
most who's that pissed off in Paris I
want to know and where were the
influencers around the Eiffel Tower and
everything doing the selfies in John
Wick's World which is a gift but no I I
mean the whole the whole thing was so
extraordinary it was just it was utterly
extraordinary um the steps the steps for
me the falling down the steps was the
win yeah the actual going up the steps
and fighting these guys wasn't as
beautiful as you know the gods of the
dollhouse I mean we had had but that but
what I found so interesting leading up
getting into this duel was so much of
John Wick and so much of this film is
about body count and just these random
guys he's popping off
and when you actually
come to the final moment and it's man
looking at another man who he's known
for a long time who has a history with
and they become humans again right yeah
they don't be they're no longer machines
they're humans and they have to look at
each other and actually fire a single
bullet you think about the how beautiful
that is and such a gorgeous am I making
you look tear up no yeah I'm just
thinking of like the humanity of it it's
just so intense like it's it's real
absolutely like I said earlier I don't
always feel like deaths are Justified or
necessary and sometimes I would like to
see different ways to end a story this
was the one ending and I I totally bald
him sitting on those stairs and having
that moment having that moment alone
the fact that Winsome left him alone
he's like take me home he sits down on
the stairs you see this gorgeous Sunrise
without even showing the wife yeah you
knew where his brain was going with that
sunrise and I thought back it was also a
full circle because the very first John
Wick the first few scenes there's a lot
of white in his house it's very white
it's kind of everything's very blown out
and that's kind of what that full circle
moment was for me visually because
everything had been so dark and then you
have the sun come up and it was such a
gorgeous moment
um
is he dead
I think so
I I know a lot of people don't and I
know they left it ambiguous but I really
think uh take me home was like his body
like take me home was he wants to be
with his wife take me home was I've
accomplished my mission I think that
like he knows it's never gonna end so
that was the closest to it ending that
he could do and I think that
he had nothing to live for
but Donnie Yen did and so it was the
gift of like you know this is this is it
uh and I also think that like it wasn't
a wound that Donnie Yen gave him that
killed him it was just like he hasn't
he's kept going through all of this like
he's just broken like I think he decided
yeah I think the moment he said because
before that he would never sort of
accept like he would always say I'm
going to kill you I'm gonna kill you he
would never sort of ponder the idea he
could die when he said this is what I
want on my Tombstone it was like he was
mentally preparing himself he he kind of
had accepted it and I think sometimes
you know if you're into psychology like
you said you're into psychology I think
you know what you set your mind to or
what you allow into your brain like the
secret kind of thing yeah he had never
allowed that to enter his brain and once
he decided
and took the jacket off frankly and he
said bye to the people he cared about
right he did like a farewell and he'd
never done that before like he said bye
to everyone that meant something to him
and then he had a beautiful moment to
leave and I I think that's uh really
impactful and and I I do again like that
they didn't show his actual physical
death but I I feel like that's it and I
and I kind of like that clean ending if
there's a John McFadden there but like I
really think that it's it's beautiful so
my big question to you is did you see
the Hollywood Reporter interview Chad
just did an interview where he said John
is dead oh did he he confirmed it okay
because I so here's what he said 99.9
sure so what he said was
they were planning on doing John Wick
four and five then he decided he only
wanted to do one and then the other and
then as they were developing for he
realized and they went to Lionsgate and
they said
here's what's going to happen and
Lionsgate went what the literally
what the are you guys doing they
shot an alternate ending oh wow where
John at the very in the funeral scene
the dog does look up but you cut two and
I don't know if they confirmed whether
he sees John or whether it's implied
that he's still alive because the dog's
looking at John and they don't show him
and when Winston says those words so
they shot an alternate ending they
showed it to test audiences and they
revolted they did not like the ambiguity
or like it's not earned yeah and so the
original ending is the ending you saw in
the movie and once they test screen the
alternate ending and realize audiences
didn't like it even though it was more
right then they decided they went back
to Lionsgate they said it's done we we
need to end it yeah that's that's
Integrity too that's integrity and they
said we're done like John's done good
Chad's Breaking Bad ended when it should
and like the when you can end on a high
note the biggest grossing John Wick like
let it be a beautiful franchise don't do
nine but I'm gonna throw a curveball at
you because then one of The Producers
was then interviewed
I don't know when the interview happened
but she talked about future projects and
she said
hopefully there's going to be they said
a sequel to ballerina we already know
the Continental we're going to announce
this other Untitled John Wick project
that we hope is nobody yep and
potentially a John MC5 so I don't know
whether she gave that interview before
then everybody saw the movie to sort of
make everybody think there could be so
nobody knew like if they said this is it
then people would knew obviously so I
don't know I don't know chicken or the
egg what came first but they did shoot
it in a way that you know when Winston
says you know is he in Heaven or Hell
the question is and his answer is you
know I don't know yeah I don't know also
he can pop up in ballerina and things
because Etc well ballerina isn't yeah
it's a prequel right so yeah so like you
can still have that moment to tie in
just to launch all that also like the
way they shot this movie was felt very
much like we're gonna do everything like
the whole movie feels so big and bold
it's like we're gonna put it all on the
table so if they did another one it's
just gonna feel like we're trying to
find new ways this didn't feel like it
was true and they went down the road and
I'll be there too and we'll all be there
because it did so well but yeah I think
at the end of the day
look it didn't feel like not showing the
close-up and and having that last line
be like oh he could potentially still be
alive I didn't feel
where it was like oh they're just doing
this so they could do another one it
really felt like a creative Choice it
didn't feel cheap at all the way that
they the universe feels ambiguous you
know like the universe has a lot of
those like heady lines like there's a
lot of one-liners in the John Wick
universe that are like Oh and it just
felt like that Baba Yaga you never know
perhaps he's gonna have an ambiguous
ending and it didn't feel you know what
I mean like he's he's the boogeyman the
boogeyman you should never see the
boogeyman die 100 because then he's not
the boogeyman right you should have him
watch the sunset cut to his grave
Boogeyman and that he stays ethereal and
John Wick is ethereal he's a he's a
force of nature he's a figurehead so I
think that was 100 The Right Move 100
The Right Move 100 worked creatively but
also works if there is to be a John Wick
five I mean it's making enough money
they might try to you know throw an
island at somebody but yeah and maybe a
couple years from now they'll be like
you know I always think that once people
put projects to bed and they come out
they're exhausted and then yeah and
they're like this is it and we're done
and then five years later like we're
rebooting it right you just needed time
off yeah you just need to rest sometimes
like when people say they're getting a
divorce I'm like maybe you just need to
be away from each other for a year and
then come back this could work out this
is not the word thing though
in real life I just want Keanu Reeves to
like maybe do a rom-com like just just
chill out like because like 12 weeks of
training for this and the physicality he
showed and all the stuff he does like
there's a reason we're all fascinated by
the man but I also like
it's so good to see someone that joyful
happy like the man like there's no bad
stories about Keanu Reeves because he's
Keanu Reeves I want him to do whatever
he wants like there's no part of me that
feels like he's beholden to John Wick 5
now which is nice I want him to do
whatever whatever he wants I know I'd
love to see him in anything it's not
like one of those actors where you go oh
God if he doesn't do this you know I
don't want to see him in anything else
but they're so attached to a role and
they're not that great in anything else
it's the opposite yeah and also even to
the point of like if you want to stick
five years off yeah I'm happy for him
it's like you're doing selfie whatever
you want where he's like our child I
love this man who doesn't selfishly I
want him on a movie a month but I also
like there's some actors like man just
live like you seem because there's not
there's not that many people that have
such an interesting philosophy on life
in the world and that translates in his
work and like you you don't get that
from just working like you don't you
don't gather these World Views by just
being on set all the time so I I think
we're gonna get better franchises by
letting Keanu Reeves go be Keanu Reeves
well you know you from when you were an
actor like if you can't live it you
can't act it no and if you don't have
life experience you can't portray
anything that said I want the lake house
too him and Sandra Bullock
remember she was spoiler alert she was
dead in it now maybe he can they can go
and often be enough bring that on you
know like a see-through lake house
anything he likes yeah
I'm there if copel is done with his
megalopolis and he wants to do a Dracula
too fine koi this has been a joy koi is
a joy tell everybody where they can find
you this is a great conversation oh you
got me down umro uh my name at Instagram
Twitter YouTube I'm growing my YouTube
I'm doing out of the theater reviews
where I basically just like hold the
camera and walk out of the theater and
ride my car and just review a thing to
show that I like one take and I don't
like repeating myself uh I also am
growing my Tick Tock and I'm launching a
new podcast soon over at the real
rejects I'm also at new rockstars and
I'm here as much as I can possibly be
and uh yeah to set up my name everywhere
I I don't like free time and I'm on the
internet and I will have just wrapped
Megacon so hopefully some interviews are
up with Membean John Bernthal Charlie
Clarkston since now for you very excited
about uh this year to come and this year
is maybe the most exciting in movies in
a long time so I feel like every two
weeks is something that's like the
biggest of the year so we're uh we're
eating well and I feel like both Indie
mid budget and Blockbuster Cinemas
thriving so get to the movies support
Cinema and uh love some art and talk
about it like art is to be shared and
discussed so as much as you can connect
to things and share that that passion
for it and I do love watching you and I
watch all of your out of theater
reactions I love seeing them I'm like
what did koi think of that they're so
much fun yeah I just love the green like
mental monologue and like then I feel
better like okay I got out of my system
yeah wow thank you all for joining this
episode of the after show we had so much
fun it's so nice when we can talk about
something that is just so so so darn
good
um and my theater was full and I hope
people keep going to see this again and
again and again we hope you will join us
next time on the after show I'm Mickey
Novak see you next time bye